hey you guys I'm Lisa from the score
eSports and we're here in sunny
Barcelona to wrap up 2016 now it's been
a huge year for overwatch so here are
your top ten best plays of the year you
know he's gonna drop that on the cart
and try and make an aggressive push I
was safe I was like one of the curators
of the museum here and I see Gupta's
comment right there I just walk out to
grab it you don't need to bring it any
farther huh Oh some barrier protects but
there's the earth shatter afterwards it
looks like hooky Panthera gonna get
wipes wow they're old economies and
working up now towards that graviton
surge so not a big commitment for a
phase either just trading Roadhog volts
basically yeah any other side night
shatter what a promise for team envyus
and they will absolutely rock phases
world that was one of the most beautiful
setup I have ever seen though so for now
the payload moving and everything blues
favorite I wish we could have seen what
had happened to the rest of NV during
that little chase they did remove Harry
hook from the fight time who's going to
look for hope right oh boy time against
what it is a whole hog pushing a
freaking blue back again they want to
take this payload out right here right
now at a very low nice right-click
prepare another one and time ooh the
hero on this row dog roll and blow a
hole goes down and there's a kind not
done quite yet
tails Manasseh hi squad just to stay
alive as that
Busan Dean is doing a lot of work
pushing it back to spawn doesn't get the
kills he will be more on to chip science
but they may be able to claim this point
here they can survive this next
offensive push from Hulk there's a
shield it's going to grow the outside
graviton surgeons used it all in bars
and it comes in and whoa that is a big
nano boost in favor of envious on that
on that right art Wow last second hold
right there response here from the
offensive gale force they make the best
out of a kind of bad situation moving in
and now they are pushing teamliquid back
a little bit hard blue still in the
thick of things torquing something offs
on widow in the back very close fight
going on yours dummy going to bite the
dust to arm Lucic for Malcolm
holy God 81 supers love are through
again with a very late whole hog and
yeah he's gonna get a killer swap he's
getting a killer three right now that's
my triple kill 1v3 forearm blue I would
say click
the fight is over when I say it's over
true heroics coming in right now for our
blue getting five kills in the last part
of this game
talk about putting the team on your back
oh my goodness humbly please
[Music]
there's definitely work out right in
here Harlow is still doing work in the
back gala take out the Lucio cartilage
that's been uncontested here for about
six or seven kills has been an absolute
joy to watch and he's a big reason why
gale force will complete this map if
they do complete this map
yeah they're kind of in desperation this
were close for the goal they can taste
it it could almost touch it but they're
not damaged it's a time bomb is about to
be here two wins that 90% of ultimate
suites have been coming for his uncle's
the taken down it's been so careful this
entire match opening up kills letters
arriving chefs gonna take him down and
win say on his liver of HP just a shield
pops go to sorry the pause button
connects on the quite a few
to get the point and a half is up
[Music]
to play
Oh
[Music]
in the command from climate it I need
this already have him so he's first
Deadeye please allow ball so James II
Natalie before too wide you see that
little fence there I hooked across the
gap from a road hook is this
his head but he was said to be perfect
on the hook that was absolutely kebab
like in the Baptist very content to sit
back in focus 76 doesn't worry about too
much getting in his face and can you
help attack bison we need to but the
offense the ground ton is out and here
comes Nicholas oh my goodness is the
wombo combo straight on it an eight-six
kill coming out from Nicholas TJ oh oh
my god you want to play tremors healed
in the way p.m. going down as well in
that fight so a couple of wasted all
fits in fact three 402 vacant by to
waste his as well or will he be able to
pull miracle he gets three really middle
to get important it's a bit gonna put
the team on his back and make this
happen here let's use myself as long as
I cameras so I think if you see ma how
many how to change is silly even further
it's finally encountered here it's about
suppose the way through but they can't
be much more than this or candy so the
two inch PT slowly focus on reinforces
money up here to help us the charts
gonna take him is he's gonna fall and
complexity
just barely but here comes the trance
and it's gonna kill us big all the way
back up we do have the may in play for
complexity justice delay and fight is 52
kills in a row and Road making it happen
there's a bit he has got another he
hasn't died in 45 seconds on the point
they needed to focus his much much
earlier but this is the final moment for
complexity they're gonna drop out of the
tournament in a row it fences sometimes
got a couple walls if it's coming here
pretty soon our shadows gonna be up but
it should have his whole hog near future
tips getting up pretty close on the
sound barrier so see what they can do
there comes the graviton surge
sweet
is going to be a wife oh nice try
is reflective in truck and there you
have it do you agree with our list or do
you feel like we missed something
let us know in the comments below I'm
Lisa from the score he sports and we
will see you guys next year